to Las Vegas now all those summer
vacations are still in full effect
Silver State Schools Credit Union the
sponsors of this next segment is running
its annual back to school supply drive
Mercedes tells us more
I'm really excited because Silver State
Schools Credit Union you guys you do so
much for the community and you know how
much you guys love teachers and students
and you guys are running your annual
back to school drives tell us a little
bit about it how do we get involved
yes absolutely Mercedes so our back to
school drive that's one of our favorite
things all year and and we uh we're
running that now through July 31st and
our members have always been uh generous
in donating supplies however we want
everybody to know in the community uh
that's listening that they can
participate by visiting any one of our
10 branch locations here in southern
Nevada to drop off any new school
donations and so uh if people always ask
you know what kind of donations and so
we're accepting all types of school
supplies pencils pens notebooks but
especially backpacks that's always their
favorite and so
um I wanted to let everybody know to
also Nations benefit our community
Through The Silver State School Credit
Union people over profit or what we call
the pop foundation and I wanted to let
you know of course the Credit Union's
employees also make the sample employees
uh school supply donation service worthy
cause because they you know as I
mentioned it it's one of our favorite
times of years and so
um and so we we definitely do something
as well and so uh school supplies will
benefit our local Focus schools and
those are Rex Bell Elementary and
Stanford Elementary but we also uh I uh
give some of those school supplies to
The Girls Athletic Leadership Charter
School uh which is a great school and uh
to find branch locations near you just
visit
silverstatecu.com
locations again that's
overstate2u.com location yeah a great
way to give back to the community and
help local students I love that you guys
do that your staff really is second to
none as a member I get to interact with
them and see how great they are but I I
hear now you have an award-winning staff
over at Silver State Schools Credit
Union and you guys continue to grow tell
us a little bit about that and thanks to
that commitment to providing excellent
member service server safe Schools
Credit Union there's actually been
awarded gold as the best credit union in
the 2021 best of Las Vegas reader school
so we continue to grow and we're
accepting applications from individuals
seeking their career in Information
Technology mortgage lending Grant
services and administration
um and I wanted to let everybody know
that Silver State Schools Credit Union
offers excellent benefits uh benefits
including medical dental and vision
insurance we have an incredible dollar
for dollar Max up to six percent on 401k
and that part you just don't hear that
anymore and folks but we're proud to
offer that and we offer a generous
number of paid holidays excellent paid
off uh uh take time off right away and
uh and so for more information on that
and still apply please visit
silverstate.com careers
thank you again to Silver State Schools
Credit Union for sponsoring that segment
call
702-733-8820 or visit
silverstatecu.com forward slash careers
for more we'll be right back on Las
Vegas now
[Music]